The technical term
for these things is
'transmission towers'.
But here in Britain,
we call them pylons.
And we've got tens of thousands
of them across the country.
The first National Grid was
built in the interwar years,
and it was the largest
peacetime construction project
Britain had ever seen.
A single power network
across the country.
Pylons became part of
the landscape of Britain,
just as they had
around the world,
despite the objections
of many landowners,
traditionalists, and poets.
These exist because
overhead lines are
a fraction of the price
of underground cables,
and they're much, much easier
and faster to maintain.
If there's a fault,
you don't need to bring in
heavy equipment and
dig anything up.
Instead, you dispatch
a team to climb.
And that team will have
learned the job here,
at the National Grid
Training Centre
near Eakring in
the East Midlands.
And today,
one of those teams
is going to take me
up on the wires.
So here at
the Training Centre,
we have over 300
graduates and apprentices
training in overhead lines
and substation technologies.
The team that
have trained here
will undertake a range of roles.
They might be overhead
line operators,
so they'll be climbing towers,
responding to faults.
They also conduct
visual inspections.
We have a team of drone
and helicopter pilots
that keep the
network operating.
And then we have
substation teams as well.
So they would look at
cleaning and replacing
different equipment
within our substations.
I haven't looked
at any point out
or down to see
how high I am.
I'm just kind of going,
there's the next bolt,
there's the next bolt.
And I'm aware that
the professionals
...are doing this
much faster than me.
And I'm fine with that.
We have a team
of 2,400 people
that monitor and operate,
maintain the network
around the clock, 24/7.
This might be in response
to weather or
faults on the network.
And they keep
the energy flowing.
Presumably, you're
up here in all weathers.
You'll have dealt with
rain and snow.
In an emergency,
they definitely work in bad weather.
Can you just take
one more step up?
Yep.
We'll attach you
onto the actual tower.
Give you
a bit more space.
Thank you.
Oh, it's not a bad view
either, is it?
Yeah, it's
not bad around here.
So what, this is first arm.
Yep, bottom phase,
middle phase, top phase.
Huh, it's different phase
of power on each arm?
Yep.
Right! That makes sense.
Because otherwise
the three would
kind of interact with
each other on the wires.
So we have 22,000 pylons.
Each pylon weighs
approximately 30 tons.
4,500 miles of overhead line,
and 900 miles of
underground cable.
Because we're
at our training school,
we've got all different
combinations
of wires in
different formations.
We've got our new towers there.
Yeah, the T-pylons.
T-pylons, yep.
Which aren't as high.
No, they're a bit lower.
I'll keep climbing.
Oh, it's getting real windy now!
You're doing good, Tom.
If you're wondering...
this is the point where
the nerves kicked in.
I don't know if
that's coming across
on microphone and camera, but...
the wind is whistling
through the metal and
through the wires.
Okay.
Well done, Tom.
(laughs) Thank you.
There's plenty of people
who don't get up here.
Mind the head.
Oh, how's that?
(laughs)
We own and
operate the network
in England and Wales.
We also operate
parts of Scotland.
This training centre was built
in the heart of the country
because a lot of the power
stations were around here,
in the Midlands and Yorkshire.
Because a lot of the coal
that fuelled those power stations
was being dug up
around here.
Not all of it – there was
plenty in Scotland
and Tyneside and
South Wales too.
And a cluster of power
stations down on the Thames.
But if you were
going to pick a spot
in the centre
of the power grid
to have the best access
of every pylon
...you'd pick here.
But things are changing,
and have been
changing, for decades.
The only coal-fired
station left in Britain
is about an hour south
on the other side
of Nottingham,
and that'll close down
within a year.
The main replacement
right now is gas,
and those stations tend
to be on the coast,
where enormous tankers of
liquid natural gas can dock.
The nuclear plants
are by the coast too,
for easy access
to cooling water.
And then there's the wind.
Britain is a windswept island!
And we already
get a quarter
of all our power
from the wind,
with half of that from
colossal fields of turbines offshore.
And there are more, and more,
and more of those being built.
Britain's entire power grid
has been steadily turning
inside out for years.
As anyone who lives in a
former coal mining community
like this knows all too well,
power generation just isn't
happening here anymore.
Electricity isn't being
pushed out from the centre.
Instead, it's being
brought in from the coast.
Alright, next stop...
Down on the wires.
I've got to be honest with you,
that ladder is swaying
a lot more than I'd like.
Aye, I'm going to
go down first,
and I'll get it a lot
more stable for you.
(laughs) Thank you!
National Grid's role is
to move energy
around the country.
We don't generate energy.
We just connect it
to our network.
It's weird to see
all this infrastructure
and not hear the bu—
I mean, I guess
if you hear the buzzing
and you're on here,
you're really in trouble.
In total today,
we have 65 gigawatts
of generation connected
to the network.
That's a whole range of sources.
So we have about
90 sources of generation.
And the government has
a target to connect
an additional 50 gigawatts
of offshore wind by 2030.
Oh!
Step down.
Okay. Like it's
any normal ladder.
A lot of metres
above the ground.
That's fine.
The ladder is angled
the wrong way.
My arms are further
back than my legs.
In order to
connect the 50 gigawatts
of offshore wind that
we're seeing out at sea,
we need to create a
series of subsea cables,
new overhead lines,
in order to move that
energy across the network.
As it stands, we know
that we need to construct
five times as much
infrastructure
in the next seven years
as we have in the last 30.
So if you just
stop there for two seconds...
Yep.
You can stand on this.
And it's pretty secure.
That was fun, okay.
(clattering)
(groans)
Okay, one foot on each wire.
Wherever you feel comfortable,
you're perfectly fine.
Alright.
Wow!
It's all
pretty sturdy stuff.
You didn't have to prove
that by bouncing though!
(both laughing)
It's impossible to disentangle
politics from the power grid.
When the National Grid
was first built,
the government had to ignore
so many complaints
to push it through.
But the benefits were obvious.
And even the folks
who rallied against pylons
would have to admit
that the result was
probably worth it
compared to no electricity.
But now, and over
the next few years,
there are going to
be political fights
and protests, large and small.
Because for the first time
in nearly a century,
there are some big
and tough decisions
to be made about pylons.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]